is a question that many of us
have Did the prophet
physically see Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala on the night of the
Ascension We have some
narrations of companions saying
that no, they were asked the
same question. I was asked this
question. Ibn was asked this
question and they were very
very strongly of the opinion
that he did not see Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala physically.
And Ibn Abes was narrated to
mentioned in another elsewhere
In another time, we don't know
really the context of that
question. Is did the prophet
see Allah and he mentioned that
yes, he saw him. But in another
wording, he said, he saw him
with his heart. So, this is not
a physical observation. This is
something that is a spiritual
observation. He mentions a few
of these issues but really if
we look at what each of the
companions is saying, they're
not really disagreeing, right?
In order for them to disagree.
One of them would have to be
asked the same exact question
as the other, correct? So, if
we had a narration that I as
she was asked, did the prophet
see Allah on the night of and
she said, no. And then that
same question and that same way
was asked to even Abbas and he
said, yes, then we'd say yes,
there's a conflict here. But
that's not clear. It's not
clear that there was a
difference in opinion or a
conflict in their responses.
Because even at best was asked
a general question. Did he see
Allah? And even Abbas
responded, he saw Allah with
his heart. Was asked the more
specific question. And that is
did he see him on the night of
and she vehement
oppose that idea and that is
because there's a general rule
and that rule is something that
the prophet told us about when
warning us of a dajel. That a
dajjal will come and claim to
be Allah. In some narrations,
the prophet said, you will not
see Allah until you die. And we
see that Musa Alaihi Salam
asked Allah to see him as well.
And
that was something that Allah
negated would happen. It cannot
happen. So, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala will be seen on the day
of resurrection by the
believers. This is mentioned
throughout the Quran. In
numerous places. As for seeing
Allah in this life, before we
die, There's no evidence that
any of the prophets or
messengers have seen Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala physically
with their eyes, right?
there's actually a very serious
difference of opinion amongst
the scholarship of Islam. If
any of the angels have seen
Allah. And the stronger opinion
is that there's no clear
evidence that any angel has
seen Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
That this is something that is
after the life of this world.
Even the angels, even Jibreel,
and Mikael, and even the angels
that carry the throne of Allah.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells
us that they believe in Allah.
He describes the angels in the
Quran. As believers in Allah.
And if they would have seen
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then
using the word belief in that
context seems a little strange.
Of course they would believe in
Allah because they've seen him.
The point of this is that many
of the scholars view that. This
kind of wording is evidence
that not even the angels of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala have
seen him.
Allah. Continues now to mention
the aftermath of Al Isra
the
[Silence]
his in the story of his
incident and part of that was
if you really went to then
describe it to us because they
knew that he had never in his
history, in his life, had
traveled to and if he had, it
was 40 years ago and things
change in 40 years. And so,
they asked him, if you really
did go there, then describe it
to us. This was a problem for
the prophet because he went
there at night. It's night
time, right? He didn't see a
lot of details. He was there at
night and saw a very small
spaces as a person would. He
goes to a building at night.
And so Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala raised for him an image
of Beetel Makdis. Where he was
able to see it and describe it
in real time. And as he
described it to them, he not
only describes but he also
describes some things that were
in progress between Mecca and
Maktis. Meaning, there's a a
caravan coming or a caravan
going and the name of it is
this and he even told them of
the name, the names of some of
the animals in the caravan,
right? And and small incidents
that were occurring like
there's a caravan coming and
it's a caravan for this tribe
or this place and it has this
many people and also one of
their camels. It's name is
this. It ran away and they're
actually trying to find this
when I passed by them, right?
This is not something you can
make up and so, the more he
would answer their questions
accurately, the more intense
their disbelief became. A
person might wonder, why is
that? Right? Well, the answer
is a person accepts a question
based on his intention for
asking it. What's your
intention when you ask a
question, right If your
intention of asking the
question is to know, to
understand, it's genuine
intention what you received
will increase your knowledge
but if a person's intention is
to be argumentative, to
challenge, to discredit, right?
This will only increase that
person's ignorance, ignorant
behavior. The people of Quraish
were not asking because they
were interested in what
happened and they believed him.
They were asking him because
they were trying to get him to
trip up in his words to make
mistakes so that they could
prove that he is a charlatan.
As according to what they
claimed. But the that he
informed them of these kinds of
details, the more frustrated
they became, and the more
rebellious they became. And so,
there's a difference, even
though the question is the
same. The same question might
be asked by two different
people and receive two
different answers or not
receive an answer at all. Make
those two people head in two
opposite directions. What do I
mean by that? So, we have in
the Quran that some of the
prophets, antagonists asked him
when is the hour? When is the
day of judgement, right? How is
resurrection going to be? What
are the descriptions of
resurrection, alright? And then
we have elsewhere where
believers ask that same
question and there's even
narrations of that. Same
question would be asked. So,
one person would ask this
question. And or two different
people would ask the same
question and get two different
responses.
One time the prophet was asked,
when is the hour? And he
responded saying, when
entrustment is lost, is
forfeited. Another asked him,
when is the hour? He said, what
have you prepared for it?
Another asked, when is the
hour, he said? I have no, I, I
don't know. I have no idea when
it is. Only Allah knows. What
does this tell us about when we
have the same question with
different answers? This tells
us that a lot about the context
of the question. You know, the
person who asked this question,
this is what the prophet
observed when he answered it,
right? That's why you see a lot
of times, that, you know,
there's, we could probably even
write a small treaties or a
small book on all the different
times, the prophet was asked,
Elsini, give me some advice.
How many times? He was asked
that same question. Give me
some advice. This one he would
say, you know, don't become
angry and this one he would
tell You know, don't be a
leader and this one he would
tell. What does that tell us?
That's a reflection of the
questioner. Person asking the
question, we can assume, do not
become angry at an anger issue,
right? Do not be a leader. Is
somebody looking for
leadership? What isn't really
fit for it? These are, these
are deductions that we take
from and to learn about the
context in which the question
was asked. So, the point here
is that Ibnal tells us that the
prophet was able to then in
detail describe
described who was coming and
going between Mecca and Al Aqsa
and even some minutia the
name of some random animal and
some random caravan, right?
That's something you could only
know if you were there. And so
he answered them entirely. Yet
his answers only increased
their disbelief. Allah tells us
in the Quran that the more
Quran comes to the prophet that
certain people who have
disbelieved the more they hear
the Quran, the more they will
disbelieve. And he tells us
elsewhere that the more those
who believe the more Quran that
is sent down, the more that
they will believe, right? And
this again goes to the
intention of the person. But
either way, when the human
being comes in contact with
Revelation and is faced with
revelation, they're not
going to be the same. That they
were before. So, one who reads
the Quran They'll never be the
same after reading the Quran.
It will either be more
misguided or they will be more
guided based on their intention
and the purity of it. And that
reading.
Even though Who are Muhammad
who knows Haq? Rahima Allah. Ha
Udalis.